[Música]
[Aplausos]
saludos gente somos culturas proféticas
y estamos aquí en la france 24
[Música]
con tu arma más letal
no me dejes escapar
william art juan carlos el iut estar con
vosotros hoy es toda una dicha muchas
gracias
tras 25 años de muchísimo trabajo de
rebuscar la de invertir todo por un buen
sonido o seguí sintiendo esos músicos de
la calle de la brea y definitivamente si
siempre
nosotros hacemos música
desde la vivencia verdad desde la
experiencia
común
y aunque no lo parezca cultura profética
es un grupo indie indie independiente no
tenemos un sello multinacional que nos
apoya y nos financia económicamente sino
que nosotros de
nuestros propios esfuerzos es que
trabajamos hacemos las grabaciones
organizamos la gira así que yo creo que
más que eso vivimos de tocar
literalmente tocábamos la pasamos más si
definitivamente somos músicos de la
hebrea y justo este año estamos
terminando nuestro estudio oficial
por primera vez en 25 años y somos
músicos de la obra
este camino quería ir precisamente de la
independencia de no ser solo vuestra
propia disquera sino también de
construir vuestro estudio cómo gestionar
esa independencia como banda porque no
sé si estar en ese lado es un tipo de
resistencia también mal
definitiva es lo que le llamamos como el
camino largo en la
cuesta empinada pero algo bien bonita es
que hemos ido en estos 25 años
aprendiendo de los errores cometidos
y de las experiencias que hemos tenido
de trabajar con diferentes tipos de
personas en esta industria que es una
industria no hay muchos tiburones
ciertamente nosotros empezamos bien
chamaquitos en esta industria verdad son
muchas veces verdad en muchas trampas de
diferentes tipos y nosotros poquito a
poco decidimos entrar en la parte que no
es la música verdad es que es la parte
administrativa que es la parte
después la parte no sé si llamarle la
parte fea de la industria de la menos
divertido y menos divertida pues
llamarle así este yo estuve un tiempo
como quien dice bregando con la final
sad directo con el contable y nosotros
verdad esté bregando con unas cosas
porque pues nos dimos cuenta que era
importante nosotros manejamos trastoque
finanzas a veces tú confías en la gente
y confía en la gente equivocada hoy día
estamos estamos muy bien no fumar está
haciéndose cargo de eso junto con soraya
que nuestro amarillo y que son personas
que confiamos plenamente y que pues
sentimos que tenemos el poder de la toma
de decisiones y que siempre pasa por el
filtro de nosotros pero nos toma mucho y
llegar hasta acá para sido unidos y es
ver nuestro nombre
compitiendo verdad como quien dice con
marcas gigantes con disqueras
multinacionales y ver que el esfuerzo de
nosotros
de esta manera tan tan bonita verdad es
como decía el de la autogestión estando
ahí de tú a tú es hermoso de las hermoso
porque nosotros no tenemos el mollero ni
económico ni de ni de todas las
conexiones ha sido porque porque también
la gente el proyecto de nosotros y se
siente mejor todavía la satisfacción es
el doble de grande
precisamente william el tema sube el
humo cantas basta de la prisa y así
habéis cocinado a vuestros seis discos
como un buen guiso de nueve años podemos
decir por eso considera hay sobrevolando
vuestro mejor disco pues sí
definitivamente pero yo yo igual si
pudiera visitar a ese willy del 2004 e
iría pero no pro casting
si todavía me lo tengo que decir
constantemente es que haces levantas
yo creo que el disco sobrevolando el
mejor disco hasta ahora porque realmente
hemos aprendido mucho de cada de cada
experiencia es un disco que además creo
que es bien
ambicioso sin ser pretencioso le voy a
decir
nos atrevemos a hacer un montón de cosas
sin necesariamente pensar como que a
esto tiene que ser un éxito si no es que
nosotros necesitamos sacar esto la gente
tiene que escuchar estos otros colores y
queremos sumar estos otros colores a
nuestra paleta eso definitivamente
es un disco muy completo porque
comprende
estética del principio hasta la de hoy
como que hace un junte de todo un poco y
propone para el futuro también muchas de
esas composiciones no sólo de
sobrevolando todos los otros discos son
himnos a la naturaleza el amor la
libertad pero sobre todo hay un
compromiso político y social dentro me
gustaría preguntaros en relación a
vuestra casa a vuestro borinquen cuál
sería la letra adecuada para describir
la la isla hoy no bajo una colonia bajo
deuda feminicidios con el
efecto dominó si ahora mismo hace
pues venimos
gobernador atrás de mucha mentira
se está creando una historia que es la
que quieren que
nosotros como puertorriqueños
asimilemos y a la misma vez está
ocultando otra historia y pues para
nosotros que
buscábamos verdad un poco más acercarnos
a nuestra raíz y entender mejor quiénes
somos para poder también a través de el
altet la reivindican
esto que somos en la puertorriqueño
creando música como tú muy bien dicen
esté basada en el amor absoluto de todas
las cosas es bien importante hacer ese
trabajo y nos lo tomamos en serio como
una responsabilidad quizás tuvimos unos
accesos a esta información verdad que es
que se esconde tanto y pues es
importante a quienes no tienen el acceso
pues tratarle exponer la verdad pero
justo cuando pasa esta revolución en que
sacan al gobernador de puerto rico que
es algo inesperado para nosotros verdad
pues sí hubo como un bus de de fe de
momento es posible sí sé si puedo creer
en mi pueblo de nuevo no puedo creer que
es que hay gente que quiere el cambio
pero pasó esto y de momento llegó la
pandemia y todo el mundo
se tapó los ojos y la boca
como olvidar la pandemia la saca para
esa curación vivimos en ella y sé que ha
sido duro para escribir duro también de
estar mucho tiempo sin este contacto y
testar un disco con la gente
precisamente eso son los conciertos
vuestra fuente de energía para vosotros
pero yo creo que como músicos nos
cuestionamos que inclusive me cuestione
como el propósito de la vida si nos
quitan las tarimas como para que vamos a
vivir no hay algo que yo personalmente
no trabaje espiritualmente como se
busque para adentro como que trate de
conectar con la naturaleza
buscar a ver que qué más hay no
y yo creo que
aprendimos bastante de la pandemia no
como como como yo creo que a
hay una pausa todavía mirar todo desde
afuera desde un movimiento más más
global de por donde nos vamos a ir qué
va a pasar de ahora en adelante
y algo importante que trajo la pandemia
que nosotros estamos bastante claros
pero nos ayudó a nosotros llevar el
mensaje del mensaje de que realmente hay
un problema de salud es clave de
alimentación de realmente cuidarnos y
darnos cuenta que la tierra nos provee
lo que los otros necesitan
y yo creo que fue importante como dijo
wang qi nosotros desde nuestro cuento
desde nuestras personas cada uno que la
gente viera eso que pues siempre nuestro
proyecto sea tratado de sobre la este
hay que aprender a desaprender
básicamente y no tenemos problema con
serlo es loco
no quería no preguntaros por algo de los
inicios que es cómo fue esa experiencia
de grabar en el estudio de bob marley
para vosotros y además un primer disco
increíble o sea literal de la palabra es
increíble yo recuerdo yo debo decir que
ya soy el más incrédulo de todo casi
siempre que bien un proceso así es
recuerdo que iván que era el pianista
original del proyecto y boris fueron
como que lo más que lo pasar fue como
que esto lo que va a pasar y de esto es
lo que yo para ustedes creen que sí
yo siempre es como que yo lo dudo pero
dar
y fue así
que ustedes quieren hacer pues queremos
grabar en jamaica para poder encontrar
el sonido correcto porque en puerto rico
ya habíamos grabado algo y sonaba como
la salsa la estética sonora no era la
que era
y pues iván hizo como un research de los
discos más importantes de reggae y
encontró el nombre del señor brawn
porque él es la institución del sonido
de rea
pues el encontró el nombre le dijo y
fácil como que llamaron y apareció y
nosotros era así de fácil entonces nos
tiramos para jamaica con 25 mil dólares
que nos dio una disquera tienda de
discos en puerto rico y con eso hicimos
todo nos quedamos todos en una casa en
madre inflable una cosa bien loca porque
la casa la cuidaba un
rasta que tenía el pelo arrastrando por
el piso
y que no era un rastro muy natural que
digan
los detalles y una prostituta cada vez
que llegábamos teníamos que ver que nos
habían quitado de las maletas nos
metíamos en su cuarto agarrarlos de
nuevo mira mi camisa y pantalón
así que nosotros somos esos músicos de
la brea y esa fue la primera experiencia
pero en el estudio era una magia absurda
estábamos en la misma casa de bob marley
en la misma casa o sea no lo creíamos
nos dábamos los los tabacos en la misma
escalera que vos antes de grabar por la
mañana una noche
qué tiene que pasar para que ellos
parafraseó que parafraseó para que
volvamos a conectarnos con esa fibra
humana de la que habláis pero creo que
creer en uno
y dejar de escuchar tanto la propaganda
corporativa que está mandando en el
mundo ahora mismo lo que realmente
estamos tomando como salud y como
ciencia no es más que propaganda y eso
es importante que lo entendamos por qué
contradecir esto no es en contra de la
ciencia sino en contra de la única
ciencia pagada por la gente que te
quiere vender productos farmacéuticos y
creo que es que si hay como que
escucharse a uno mismo y creer también
que lejos de que se escucha poéticamente
new-age decir que somos vibración y
energía entender que sí lo somos y que
es importante no solamente
vernos y hablarnos si no está el de
cerca porque nuestros campos
electromagnéticos se comunican y nos
entendemos mejor y es importante que
entendamos eso eso ha sido un verdadero
que hacer muchísimas gracias por haber
estado en france24 y a ustedes
muchísimas gracias ya saben qué hacer
escuchar cultura profética gracias
[Aplausos]
la dura que acecha en las noches cuando
es
pokémon tartas
en la frialdad tocándote a la puerta
y no recordar si la dejas
es solo mal sueño
vale mucho más que esta
pasado
recuerda
[Música]
y